hello everyone happy Monday I'm joined
by Eric Tay what's up and we are playing
demons demons souls yeah I didn't put
the esses in the titles so we'll have to
fix that later so I've only played like
blood-borne on show blood-borne
and Dark Souls 3 and like all the DLCs
and all that stuff
I've never played to one or Demon Soul
Demon Souls came out before yes correct
so part of the reason why we're
streaming two is because the servers the
online servers for demon souls will shut
down February I think of 2000 you can't
think this February 28 so it's kind of
like I don't know
well it'll be nine years next year give
or take
and then there's so much fan-out all
right pretty good so this is gonna be
real interest this is fun this is your
like history lesson I know I'm hoping
one thing that the the fan community
with the souls have always done is they
like to do these um like events where
they're like hey everybody on this day
or this weekend we're all gonna start
playing like Dark Souls 1 that way you
can get all of those cool like them
online you know yeah
experiences that you don't really
wouldn't get what should I name this
what do you normally name usually my own
name my Twitter handle and this one this
one's gonna be a bummer when it dies
because even more so than the other ones
this games got a lot of weird elements
that are very dependent on the online
experience it's got this thing called
like world tendency which changes the
way I remember how world tendency
actually functions but essentially oh am
I talking to a paper bag bump all the
way just bump both of us all the way low
hey everybody oh now I can hear you cool
yeah so the world tendency in this game
basically affects the way the world
works and like what shows up and what
monsters show up you got the experience
John Luke yeah what am I looking at ok
so I I have way more confidence in the
newer games like I could go anything in
those but wow there's a lot more choice
or no I guess it's about the same this
is obviously the most balanced obviously
there is hunter keep going priests
magics obviously a good country cheese a
lot of this can you grab with like rains
and wanderer I believe the one you want
is
I keep going well I think royalty
I think royalties maybe the the good
cheese one that everyone likes do I need
- cheese - I believe it's royalty but
you said that everyone will call me a
filthy cash if is it the one is this
like the equivalent of the pyro yeah I
believe I don't want to be a filthy cash
send that also filthy cash that's the
thing people's definition of you can't
what did you please everyone I think I
just played basic soldier
Jeff mer saying is this your first
playthrough I believe that you'll have a
good time playing it yes this is my
first playthrough of Demon Souls just go
royalty I guess but I don't like range
here basic ash [ __ ] night we'll go Bab
here we go alright do we wanna do we
care about this
oh the east and the west and the north
and the south I mean it's just random
how ugly do you want your character no
no that's the thing are we doing that
like are we just kind of okay that's
true that's true all right we'll go with
that whatever the game no no all right
let's just do it let's just is males
wandering hello what is this game guys
it's like Dark Souls yeah this is the
predecessor to Dark Souls demons with an
S soul Souls okay so here's the thing
about this game it is not as tough as
you think really
no brought unprecedented I'm also House
Verity - he's nominated a more funny
time like weird stuff sweet Arya was cut
off from the outside world
and those who dared penetrate the deep
fog never returned
but valor facts of the Royal twin fangs
broke free from the father and told the
world of bullet arias flight rights that
the old king allant had aroused the old
one
oh no the old least below the new one
from its eternal Sun in the blood borne
and that a culinary park had swept easy
unleashing terribly different ones
rebels the demons hunt down middle and
clairebear souls those who lose their
souls a greasy Genesis from investments
the man attacked the same and chaos
reigns valor effects spoke of the
enticing power of the demon souls Jeff
also says he thinks the games are hard
at the time he even claims a human soul
okay the demons owner soul is
invigorated by the life force and the
power of a mature demon soul is beyond
human imagination on death the legend
spread quickly
mighty warriors were drawn to the
accursed land but none have returned
it's up to me it'd be all over the twin
fangs Europe the silent chief oh is this
like Dark Souls 3 where they sell you
all the big bad guys yeah they're like
this 6th Saint Astraea and her knight be
like 6 bosses in 7th grade education
yeah there's a lot more I know those are
all deep fog slowly creeps beyond bullet
areas borders using the pest control
mouse people I even know you can play
this game with options the deep focus
was always better controller though
lands is it serviceable I've never tried
okay playing these things a mouse
keyboard I always yeah neo is gonna get
keyboard mouse support Syria Savior or
have Deena I'm a slave Dan you a slave
okay here's my opinion the difficulty of
this game I don't know guess the thing
with demon souls is it is less concerned
with being fair than the other games
okay it's more in like a harder way or
like a like in both its so I think the
lair games in the series were more like
a little more formulaic about more like
okay these are the types of experiences
people like this game is more willing to
just try these interesting things
sometimes that results in sections that
are really easy and sometimes that
results in sections that are really hard
oh it's a game that's just more
interested in trying out different stuff
and I think that makes it maybe like one
of the more unique games in the series
okay I think what I liked it being fair
yeah
troll are not saying that the game's
difficulty is probably in between Dark
Souls 1 & 2 so when I was saying that it
was like harder than what whoa what
happened logging in is it because we're
not know we're logged on what we got I
don't know I tried to spam through the
whatever that was see what is [ __ ] I
didn't get to read it either I just saw
that it was like an online message thing
skip there you go okay we're there we go
we're good yeah god I've been playing
you know so that's why r1 r2 right okay
yeah what's up buddy
I don't block wait so then in theory
triangle would give me dual wield
there's there's no is there no dodge
sorry not doing wheel to hand what you
ant yeah yeah yeah triangle yeah not God
I don't know how to play anymore I have
to play neo for so long so this ex was
dodging you know I just pressed that and
it did nothing there is no in this game
herbs right yeah it's it works the same
way as Resident Evil okay like miles
yeah it's like oh my god it's so slow
you're a knight you're wearing a heavy
armor what do you expect I was a knight
in blood Oh blood-borne it's a very
different game fine I was a knight in
Dark Souls 3 and I could roll faster
than those 3 is also faster no I have
not oh man yeah
one in twos ok ok at least at least it's
a it Oh God oh that didn't hurt
you're tanky man your take your take oh
I don't know what that life's like oh I
could take you oh wait I switched
weapons yeah Dark Souls 3 is
significantly faster like they'd they
upped the speed because of I think I
don't think it's because of one born but
I switch weapons no you trying to switch
oh it's I didn't hit the pad earlier
though oh okay that is so weird I'm so
used to taking like way more damage than
that a lot of people recommending to
take off some armor like play Knight but
then take off maybe your gloves and
helmet Oh to get lighter Oh am i add
that right now we got to cover our face
we look real ugly quality of life oh I
need that green I need a green lower
arrow or red all the menus in the
Seavers do you know if I'm under there's
no y there you go item burden yeah now
you're below it so can I put nope
actually you're not nevermind oh no I am
I am I just can't put the chest piece so
if it's 40 as long as I'm at 20 it's
fine right
in theory what's red alright I think
that's fine oh yeah I feel nimble baby I
feel nimble nah dude check off the chest
yeah yeah the chest was too heavy the
chest was 22 it put me at 22 oh yeah
that grass I need that grass I Dec is
saying yeah I just thinking that magic
is overpowered in this game it is which
is why I was saying if you play this
yeah but I'm no casual all right but
then I feel like there's like I've seen
playthroughs of this before like I don't
think like know that the locations are
set but there are like bigger bosses
that I'm like woah how the hell would
you kill these guys with normal way you
know I mean like why would I fight that
guy cuz like
in blood-borne Dark Souls even though
they're really big you can you know you
get your way into like be damage to
themselves Oh gotcha okay like like I
think that's probably the biggest thing
I can say about this game versus the
others and I think like especially Dark
Souls 3
reached a point where a lot of the
bosses were very like say me learn the
strategy for most of them or they have
like one or two trick here's a big boss
with like a tricky mechanic that's very
like timing sensitive or here's like a
duel fight this game has that and
they're very good but this games more
willing to like get weird with and be
like here's a weird puzzle boss here's a
you know all right well I'm failing now
cuz I think I'm probably maybe I drop
down from that where that ledge was
because I'm pretty sure that door is
closed and nothing else seemed a really
message I never read the messages before
really gave away too much so I think
that we're supposed to drop down here
yeah this is my guess man we're gonna
lose health
hey oh there's no like air attack sign
not in this where you can drop down and
I try to remember they all blur together
come at me a bro oh just let me your
comments to not get out all the secrets
of the game John Luke yeah oh definitely
I don't want to spoil it
I'm just trying to trying to give him a
vibe of how this game operates compared
[ __ ] alright those guys earlier weren't
doing that lunge attack so now I gotta
learn something else
thanks tutorial are all the guys this
easy even not in the tutorial how-to
curiosity or sorry enemies now there's a
good variety what's this
yeah all right there's some real I mean
I I didn't know if I need to explore
some more that the the guy the RPG guy
in me was like I should kind of look
around there might be some more herbs or
something there's there's some real
areas in this game that are some real
real rough Oh Josh on the chat Oh baby
this is what you wanted oh all right
this guy's got hardware yeah yeah I
don't know how demon souls but he played
that's not bonfire there's okay fair
enough you'll see oh man look at how how
far is aggro distance was good to know I
can only swing about three times up or
down so it seems like the chat we're
definitely in a lot of to have played
this game but we're also getting a lot
of people who seem to have not oh why
does that guy look way harder than the
last guy yeah I'm sure I never played
this game when it launched how old this
game spot well this if you're asking how
old we are as a site we're are like 21
now I think we had our 20th anniversary
last year this games about yeah 9 next
year because 2009 right yeah some items
where those items at John Luke I want
that guy's sword oh yeah so it'll
actually be these daggers it'll shut
down around the actual 9th anniversary
okay okay that's good to know demon or
Dark Souls now is the time to get into
demon souls everybody before that online
gets shut off thanks yeah I mean you got
like three months you'll still be able
to play the game but you really are
gonna be missing like a lot of work it
makes the game special I feel like it's
this is annoying
where's my kick do I have kick no damn
it
so this is play Kingsfield we actually
have a copy of Kingston Hills
I found it check it out just for the
sake of it but I've heard it's not very
good so I like that the physics are
still in here man they took those out it
too and that's the worst thing about
that game actually but that was a real
disappointing gonna do the old slow walk
you never know when bad guys are under a
remaster of this game there was a lot of
rumors I remember like a year or two ago
that he was working on a remaster oh god
that guy's got a crossbow
what cuz Sony technically has the
license for this I believe yeah you're
an idiot they have the license and
remember how it works I know they they
they published the game in Japan and
then Sony USA passed on it because they
had no faith in this game and they
thought it was just like a bad game and
so atlas and published it here and that
was the atlases benefit because I think
it became like the number one selling
like game ever for Atlas
just like the blacksmithing thing all
right that's come here face me here
someone saying it's from the front from
software still owns the lessons today
always not do anything those guys seems
like they always so here's a question
how do you how do you like the like kind
of like blood-borne style where you kind
of have you know either crescent moon
grass here or vials versus like Estus
flasks because there's definitely a very
big difference right like some people
are like oh it's too easy because you
can just farm them whereas like Estes
bias it gives you that kind of like that
panic I guess like knowing like am I too
far out you know can I keep going or
should I go back
[Music]
you know what blood-borne is built
around that macam yeah because you want
to be I guess you want to be a little
bit more aggressive in that game I think
when that runs into an issue is where
you there the reaches a point where say
you're really like it's ready you're
getting stuck on a boss and then you run
out of blood bowser like on i got to go
back and grind a couple yeah go for
that's that's a boss i feel like it is
god damn it oh this guy looks familiar
actually never mind you play Dark Souls
you would even know no I wouldn't
oh that was - whoops
I rolled too early death number one you
guys can count it man first dodge was
good
I would replay blood-borne see Libra
that's a good game to replay I'm gonna
get a pro soon I think
and I finally bit the bullet and bought
a 4k TV but then you said they enhance
there's a pro edition of blood-borne oh
well there's no probe there's no
official probe
yeah oh so it's just uh just um you turn
on that mode where it can take advantage
of like the hardware oh I was supposed
to die that's why I was of course you
can't can you kill him you can kill him
and if you kill him you then fight
another boss that will kill you no
matter what from its vessel
Alette strength be grant so the world
might be mended might be men so this
whole area here it's called the nexus is
you can see like the fire Firelink
shrine from three it's like heavily
influenced
by this one okay we're just good news I
think this is probably like one of the
best areas the next yeah my bad guys I
scrubbed it up I didn't know you kill
that guy with my first try right I
I definitely rolled early there on his
sweeping attack witches died that
wrapped your soul you cannot escape a
nexus so that's interesting it gave me
my souls back then um you have half your
health now when you die every time yeah
sections you got it you got to get your
you got to get yourself back oh that
wasn't a ring looks like a ring yeah a
lot of people are asking what this game
is on it's only available on ps3 what is
this I would love a remaster at this
game I think that'd be really cool I
don't know if it'll ever happen but wait
sorry so when a 50% I do get my alright
I have to find my body to get my I'm
trying to remember is that you find your
body
[Music]
when I came to I would be happy to like
the items and you know how often do I
have to repair my weapon I just do what
you got what you got
does he have anything good that I should
be buying heater shield can he afford it
and I brought the maiden in black I
think the main name blacks voice actress
is actually the same don't kill the
NPC's like I did you should know that
right you don't you don't kill them till
you get really far in the game and you
have a save and then you check this game
this team does that it tries to like
force you to I think there's a ways to
get around it but don't make decisions
where like it's like no should I be
exploring this John Luke or is that all
waste time I mean you can you can kind
of look around there's people to talk to
stuff to get okay but if you just want
to get into it we can just get like am I
missing out on anything by not it works
the same way as three where it slowly
fills out meetings yeah more people
start appearing there's like quest you
can do that people are asking there's
some [ __ ] items though like Dark
Souls 3 we could roll and get like a
like HP ring in the firelight shrink
fire oh I'm sure there is
people are talk about like the item
duplication which okay so the same voice
is the doll from blood-borne that's what
it right that's what that's good that's
equally good oh [ __ ] am I supposed to go
to her well that's kind of the thing
that like I like the this we're supposed
to go okay so basically the way it works
is oh [ __ ] I'm warping the areas yes
there are these different archstone's
that each go to different areas of the
game and you're kind of going through
them does it matter which one I go to
technically pick any one you want but
the first one there is one there is one
you would click on that one yes this is
the first there's this is probably like
a good starting all right let's go here
alright let's go here just because you
know day one you know Demon Souls virgin
hear someone saying find patches and
kill em so patches in this case oh yeah
alright
oh alright someone saying can you play
Dark Souls 3 do and just play through
mall do we do I've done three though
yeah you've done three I didn't beat the
very very there's like one extra boss in
three that I didn't beat but it's never
done I've never done Steve missiles one
into yeah and then wanted to but I think
for me like for it'll still forever be
blood-borne Donny's saying to put your
boots on
oh I can alright I'll put my boots on so
now I'm gonna be fine Oh had to fight
that oh my God he's got so many things
to eat is he like the first boss in this
area don't trust patches you got it I
don't trust it oh that's we definitely
don't have that controller or that that
cord no if I put my pants on I'll be too
I'll be overburdened I'll go try and
find something all right you do that
yep all right half my life no problem oh
[ __ ] oh I see you I see you
Oh
Oh what my bad
do we have need to ask John Luke later
if there's like staggering there's gotta
be right
I don't like all the damage I took her
right here though what's up Macari those
birds bad man that it's always so much
more nerve-wracking the first time
playing through any type of Souls game
because so much more crap is happening
like you just don't know where the
enemies are so then it becomes way more
nerve-wracking
then whoa oh no okay luckily I had my
shield out see that was weird
I didn't not hit my d-pad got it I have
a ps3 someone says bloodstains yeah
there's bloodstains in this game it's
funny how much I think a lot of people
don't realize how many things that they
take for granted in Dark Souls oh you
know what I was gonna ask you is there
um butch McCall it's like step
but uh yeah do I have to fool are to to
backstab though I'm trying to remember I
think dressing weapons are usually quite
strong oh you know what I could do is
probably put my boots are just you know
we stream on Twitch YouTube and our own
site as well so feel free to pick
whichever one works best for you that's
correct
every day at 11:00 although this week
might be a little weird we'll have to
see
yeah we're doing yeah Wednesday game of
the year best of o best of 2017 2017 oh
yeah so the so the thing with that just
so you guys know is that's going to
start want to say December 11th is one
that's gonna start oh hello
Oh yep there it is did it on purpose
guys not really but that will start the
11th we'll be doing like a countdown of
games from our like 10th to our first
which will that then be that that will
be game of the year and sorry this is
just yeah so we'll be doing that and so
join us for that live we'll be counting
down 10 yeah for our best of 2017
there's a particular game that happens I
don't even know what you're talking
about so I'm not gonna theory crap
there's no funny thing about it go down
there probably yeah it's terrible
oh yeah I knew it
I've been seasoned I've been season to
know your freakin BS the first timers
played it right when it came out because
you have no idea what you're getting
yeah well yeah I mean I've been
conditioned right at this point whereas
fry yeah for the first time all right so
what we can do some stuff go pull that
old
still too heavy that's [ __ ] that
still too heavy taking off a weapon
didn't matter and putting the shield
back on then quickly trying to behind
them sneak up on him I mean I guess it's
kind of good that they went with the
like kind of like the vile route or
whatever cuz now I don't feel that
worried about just using them but I
guess I kind of explained it basically
like the way this works is pretty
different there is no there's only like
one singular bonfire if you will in each
area and but what it does is it loops
around itself so there's way more we
move the light on showing us
yeah that's definitely the thing about
this game that I'd say it's very
structural layout of the areas and kind
of the way the game progresses is very
different which had like a passive world
- which was a little bit more of a like
a straight line with some branching
paths and then it was kind of more like
history was kind of like that - maybe
like a mix between 1 & 2 this one's more
like 5 distinctly separate okay so this
is newer for me - it's like normally fog
for me represents a boss but it doesn't
seem like it always does okay other
games I heard noises to fight me like a
man big boss says blood-borne is better
than every other thing I can't do that
arguments as I haven't played my
favorite personally honestly I think
there is a a good argument to be made
for almost every game this is feeling
fine though it's surprisingly like for
me I always thought this game would be
and part of the reason why I didn't go
back to play these when I played
blood-borne and then I moved on from
there was that it just I thought it was
gonna be a lot more plotting and slow
and like I have to block and I don't
want to block oh god I mean yes but it's
not as bad as I
Wow he swapped it at best that was a way
I don't know how that didn't but sure
it's weird having that little glowing
thing because I remember you had to turn
your Lantern on I just okay not burning
oh I'm dead
so my life gets halved again I'll find
out mistakes were made
I tried to Yolo you can't Yolo demon so
it looks good okay but I gotta get
through that all the way Dark Souls 2
does it if I recall is that
this one I think it's just always
don't ask we're gonna play shot the
Colossus again I mean when it comes out
we're probably mm-hmm someone was
recently asking me this morning actually
what uh-oh oh well stutter they're what
games I was excited for still happening
but I was saying that I think one of my
most exciting games yeah a triple
backstab come at me hey goob who's askin
flashback Mondays well there's not
really much happening there's a sort of
a reason and no God the audio the
reasoning is oh oh yeah baby
the remix is awful it's alright well
I'll try to get to them to the next it
is hitching I was playing this recently
last year well it was fine until just
now right right so now should I like go
back to the area and start it over
because I don't know what else to do
still good you want to get married yeah
I guess so you want to go full camera
the game because we're a I just do I
just held down the PlayStation button
just turn it off yeah anyway guys let's
see they planned the disc version now
we're playing digital so shouldn't have
any issues with like the discs or
anything like
I don't know why like I said oh yeah
recently last year and it was let's give
it a go it was fine just now like yeah
yeah I like thought it might have been
something just lingering like there for
a second but I guess not
yeah Chris prayer touched my neck saying
he's kind of shocked that a demon souls
is faster than he thought it's faster
than I thought for sure
so his blood-borne - coming I have my
doubts I mean I week me and John Luke
always like to talk about and I hope
that it'll happen but like I don't every
time there's like any sort of Sony thing
we're always like you know this word
they're gonna announce it all so it's
like heart it's hard to think that it
would happen cuz Miyazaki's supposedly
working on like the armor core game
right yeah and I don't know if it was
you that told me but he was like yeah
like he probably wouldn't do it unless
there's just like a boatload of money
and like maybe even then he would just
like consult and then have someone else
kind of make it was that he's done with
it and he said that if someone else in
the studio wanted to pick up the mantle
that he's like all for that he's if
there's enough passion with the team to
want to continue he's okay with them
doing I just think he's personally yeah
he's he wants to kind of go do something
different or at least a little bit so
then a lot of people kind of obviously
it was some people like it a lot but
demon souls are sorry Dark Souls 2 is
considered like the weakest one in the
series and that's the one that has the
least amount of his involvement yeah he
was just kind consulting so I think a
lot of people pointed that as don't do
it unless he's on it exactly like hey
maybe they shouldn't make one without
him because you know that's what I would
say personally well I don't think it's
like as much as I want a second book
board I don't want like a shitty mr.
second I wouldn't want one unless they
feel passionate about it and they can
make something that's like really
awesome
all right very I do not think our souls
do it as I think it's okay I do have a
lot of issues with that game but I also
think people there is another place
there is a Sony event still this year
lie Lulu 25 there's PSX that's gonna
happen soon I think it's early December
but they're not doing a press conference
are they there is something I think
there is something I don't think it's
like that long don't quote me on that
you can double-check or Kris prayer
which is toast my own accents which
could probably tell us if there is a
pretty sure there is because this the
Paris oh yeah that they might have
loaded that up go back to game oh yes
all right back in it hopefully so far so
good I just have to not die I guess
hoping for eventual I want it you want
like a remake or remaster I want a
remaster in the okay in the sense that I
want it to visually look very impressive
I don't want them to change the game
yeah yeah like I wouldn't want them to
be like well we're gonna make it faster
we're gonna get rid of some of this
stuff we're gonna change all that that
weirdness in there just make it looks
nicer and make it 60fps do all that
don't change the game don't change the
game like really special I wouldn't want
them to mess with that
how far is this first ball not a
curiosity oh that's that close I just
wanted to know so I could try to get
there maybe before that yeah so I mean I
can try to run through that stuff but
it's like one of those things were since
I haven't played it I don't know where
to go it's just it's not that you won't
get lost
okay it's pretty oh that guy just ate it
okay that guy ate it too it's much more
linear right there's there's a guy here
come on I want to say yes that's why
it's gonna be hard for like anyone else
to like do anything with it right but
but they could make like another game so
that's the only reason I could see blood
weren't you happening outside of the
what's more likely though blood-borne
Tornillo 200%
I mean you know that studio was really
passion about that game it took him like
a really long time to make it yeah I
mean that game that single-player was
way longer than I thought it was gonna
be so I think so maybe like that's kind
of where souls fans are gonna have to
think so
for blood-borne fans I guess yeah either
one now for now I think I put my hopes
more on a neo to than I would a again
unless Sony Rosa
oh no good we don't mean like they're
gonna announce it right away or anything
the game still only came out this year
the likelihood yeah I always proposing
the question to John Luke morals like
dude what are the odds or what are the
better odds I guess is this my souls
back
oh this is where I died giving my life
back this is blood-borne right copy
Jesus says won't sunny wanna put
distance between the Neo sequel and
their new sucker punch game I mean it's
not what we not that kind of game you
think yeah one we have no idea what that
kind of game is but I think that game's
gonna come out pretty relatively soon I
guess so
well did you read that one article I
think he came out today that Sony was
actually like kind of starting to get
worried about how they've been showing
off games like way too early
yeah exactly what's that is that uh is
that like armor break this yes like the
kick yeah that's like kind of like your
shove okay so yeah I bet you that game
is probably coming out like and to the
year next year and and neo
but do you think that game will be that
like that though the second punch game
no idea oh crap
nailed it I think I can drop down to get
that maybe it says do you think neo2
would go for a different setting slash
feel cool one where the protagonist is
actually agents mache that'd be kind of
cool I always wanted a I think my dream
game was like a minute Dark Souls and in
space like I'm like a dead space type of
game oh yeah more sci-fi or cert that's
the surge one it was better than Lords
of the Fallen but I also didn't go quite
as far as I wanted it to like that games
more like meki I wanted like the Dark
Souls
Oh take that weird monster design here
was ooh bastard sword
oh let's upgrade baby Dee cases Brad
shoemaker feed this game in one setting
can you do that air keep beat in one
sitting
no I'm not strong it oh god oh let's
play series but I don't think so I mean
how long is this game roughly
and is there one of those things where
you can skip like bosses and things like
that to get to where you need to trying
to remember I want to say there Oh cuz
you have to go from area D blood was
crazy because like say like half even
more of the areas like that game says I
am really quiet
you just gotta talk talk louder hey
everyone how's it going that sounds
better sweeping attack what
oh no that's me away camera gube sank
feels like neo has the formula down they
could just travel to new island to
Clintonville or something yeah I would
I'm kind of agreed that I would like
more I would love to just yeah I don't
yeah I'm curious what they're gonna do
but I love the gameplay style of these
kinds of games but I think blood-borne
kind of proves like oh you don't have to
make as red harder than blue what that
dude red eye is red eyes black dragon
harder than blue eyes white dragon
all right oh man oh he's coming at yes
okay
you know I did not see that coming
oh not the dyeing necessarily I didn't
think that would one-shot me I am rather
upset
it's a lot of guys I gotta kill so ones
asking if we've seen monster hunter
world Dustin has yeah I've never played
a monster I have not either but that one
has me more interested because I don't
play had help that much so that was the
big do you think this is a mistake
running well I didn't think his stabbing
range was that far
alright somehow those guys died which is
good Bob Jones was just saying to leave
in the heart of the cards apparently I
didn't oh I don't know how that didn't
hit me but alright I found a video
online
I recommended it was you're watching
yeah stream I was watching a video
someone made of the chats reaction went
dark magician girl showed up the first
time it was pretty funny oh my I usually
there's a lot easier to run through
these things but this guy is
we got a stream to to do here I honestly
don't remember how many guys there are
short rebreathe get some life oh god
he's so mad but then this is where it
gets real sticky to try to run by
everyone whatever
no oh one of those
prepare to rage moments when you just
roll off the ledge oh yeah Eric what's
up no sorry Eric in the chat yeah he was
on New Game+ 17 when you stopped playing
damn this I think so geez that's oh you
gained +2 I think well yeah yeah so the
thing for me with back with blood-borne
was I instead of new game oh oh oh
did you just save scum to get all the
endings I didn't save scum to get all
the yeah I didn't save ok so I didn't
save scum to get all the endings what I
did was I ended up making a new
character because I wanted to play like
a deal of year right right so then
instead in a New Game+ definitely a
blood-borne once or twice at least and
then I made a new character and got the
other ending so yeah all right [ __ ]
so he can one-shot me
well maybe not because I have full life
now but hello
oh I did damn it I didn't have
confidence I didn't have confidence in
the show oh he tried to shove me oh I do
like no damage and he can almost kill me
maybe rod okay all right what do you got
behind you what's behind door number one
oh I'm trying oh is that the boss why do
I have to look at loot I should have
just opened the door it's the items are
never worth it the items are never worth
it 100%
oh you guess six offline you're lucky no
screaming spirit I believe it is online
we should be online theoretically come
scrape me I got no levels yes I got
nothing you can scrape me if you want
real [ __ ] PvP weapon that just
removes your levels it's is it just
gonna hit once and you lose levels or is
it hard to get the scraping spirit
[Music]
no actually no no not at all uhyou Forge
it from the soul of a boss of a really
early boss so now screw it
come on buddy
just leave me be so once they imagine it
from Devaney Kingsfield big open world
third person uber game was it in the
same game as this this salad there's a
lot of people point to King shoulders
like the first person okay it's really
not very good anyone know if that door
was the boss though well don't I didn't
do any I mean I guess I don't have to
worry about my soul the other way has a
blue-eyes White Dragon and a foggy door
I think was the other way like a
shortcut you think it was a shortcut no
that's a shortcut but I'm pretty sure
was an optional area because I was
trying to remember it and here we go
it's Dan's blue eyes this way instead I
rolled right into that definitely easier
thanks
Oh God
yeah he the other guy would have killed
me I'm like what go whoa this guy Oh
grunting all right clearly might know oh
yeah the old the old look at the draw Oh
Oh God
this guy's not easier this is how I'm
supposed to be playing the game huh my
block oh you son of a B okay all right
then the freaking hunters do that yeah
that's the word okay Harris yeah
dude the one guy in the chat the church
later on that guys talking about
for the Eileen requests are you better
give me something good all right how do
I shortcut cuz obviously I have better
herbs so no I shortcut this guy
No dang it Oh hit um we're sorry that
circle I swear
nope sorry she's trying to put it into
top slot to the to make it why or trying
but I tell sauce magic oh really
so how do I change this to the bottom
hit square now remember nope it just
used it that it did what it actually
said it was gonna do reorganize nope
[Music]
which one
this wasn't equipment oh yeah but how do
I make that the this slot okay alright
we figured out the menus ah [ __ ] that
fog door
are you the boss are you a shortcut that
you said I was coming close to a
shortcut I believe so
like it's been a bit all right it's fair
so like why the fog
I should have saw that coming I should
have saw that coming
all right well then demon souls just
keep on going welcome to a Souls game uh
yeah it's been a while it's okay
got to be a masochist to it just enjoy
that experience to really just and it
doesn't matter because we gave up all
our souls anyways so what difference
does it matter Josh asks what does to
have to do and guys play more really now
you let me down the stairs yeah I hope I
die it's fine it's totally
well Josh does do a shot I don't know
who took home that that fire
oh no no I think it's something I'm good
I'm definitely not taking a shot with it
you know how many shots I would have to
take god the shots would be the death of
me probably well you wouldn't take shots
with that rock you guys see that bottle
for me
oh why
burning through my herbs Oh kuba if you
send another one next year out it I do
not know what we're gonna do yeah well
I'm out of the other one oh you're out
yeah one of those moments where you know
like just for the stream sake
cuz I'm pretty sure I'm out of the other
stuff yeah I'm out of all the scrub
herbs that we got from the tutorial oh
my god playing sloppy see this is what
happens this is that that stupid
terrible cycle where you're so sick of
the old stuff that you've been doing
here right like that I'm getting real
careless because like I just don't I
just want to get back to where I was at
but that's when you start making the
dirty the bad mistakes
I do not want to fall with you buddy all
right all right hopefully there's a boss
at that other area I don't think that
the problem is over I get one shot but
whatever or we try to go near those red
eyes black dragon again I don't hope
that the church door is actually
something what it probably isn't it's
this guy took so many of my herbs though
man there's also a path down that
hallway too
I think that's a ledge you can make it
come off you want me to push him off
that don't try to do anything you can't
do
I did not um okay dude chill no I don't
deserve these chances
if I recall once you learn the the trip
like parries and backstabs in this game
what's the trick I don't know I've never
been good at it oh yeah give me some
grass back we need it all right so I'm
better off going this way I was a
curious cat
got a pan that camera that sound like
bad news so as Mike levels our way
trough one guy's normal talk is as loud
as yelling oh this is way too quiet it's
just it's probably me I'm yeah yeah
idiots I'll try and talk louder guys
yeah keep going why is this a good or a
bad thing I think this is the shortcut
we need the shortcut job
yeah yeah yeah here it is here it is
what'd I do slice it yep and slice the
other one
the ladder I think that maybe opens the
door I keep going down wait actually go
back I keep going down we can't watch
this chance this could mean the end of
the stream if I don't get this stupid
shortcut I really would like you to find
at least one boss I would too boy for
those explosive barrels yeah let's get a
god
oh yeah yeah you didn't die though
please work
damn it it was foolproof plan John Lee
okay slow and slow and steady no oh
you're fine
oh you're fine oh just don't die thanks
John Luke thanks I don't know where the
other guys that lever then whole lever
don't you dare
I got it i framed alright yeah alright
so we got that so that's what we need to
do right hmm city alright alright now we
can go through that other area and then
really hope that there's a boss near
there and not die to that [ __ ]
throwing the fire bomb again hopefully
it's
and
all right really hope the boss is nearby
I feel like I haven't leveled up yet
either which is kind of annoying but who
is this my body touch my body do it do
it
bring more soul slayer of demons do it
how is he not in what he's so close
pitch there we go
please give me some grass he's got the
advantage with this I am panic rolling
don't mind me guys just need some dank
herbs good all right come on come on
I would he's only saying we left behind
the hairpiece man I what hair piece I
don't know I don't have time for games
my knowledge of this game what do you
think this way or that way chat which
way is the boss oh this looks like bad
news so I've only ever played this game
one time well I think I've played
I've played every Dark Souls at least
twice except well now I've played so
many guys there you can get down there
but bait-and-switch
up huh oh but I can't go back in okay we
just got to fight him over here we got
to do the old I don't have the I don't
have the cojones oh come on I got a wide
sweeping swing Oh got real lucky
no that was there's so many more guys
someone says go right for vendor I think
they're referring to that other area all
right over here do what if they're
trolling us man plays he got oh he's got
got that grass but I can only afford so
much grass so everybody the shitty grass
or the good grass you find the shitty
grass
you know by like five so that we have
some so level up it's got a club spear
can't afford on soap or soap or job
tailing at all no man I'm trying to just
like recall just game works
ready a brave knight or depraved slave
the demons will snatch you soo then you
go bad it's just the end of great pulpit
hell at least the demons don't send us
to one okay final commentary yeah you
want me to let me take a look here
check that world time to see the world
tendency nothing good to know yeah you
have to level up with me that's great
absolutely great right here we go
right so that guy is that even a thing
that we can get across
there's so many this guy you like okay
probably go like that way this but yeah
there's a lot of extra stuff around here
if I recall but what I do
oh yeah yeah that I haven't equipped
yeah I saw I did pick that up I think
just now so it's clinging oh yeah
where's that do you lose less HP one
insole form which is what you're
currently you got some light back I'm
like ooh that's good oh man do I have to
you can't jump in this game right that
way can you jump I remember like you
know how you could do the running Bo
no not like this hi I would like to use
my sword art move on you know oh nice
just just please die yeah oh wait you
grass that must be the dankest of moobot
still tell me people to donate to
extralife well you should you can please
moon grass no is the boss think so we
closed what is that why why there's so
many of these dudes here you got a
firebomb
I definitely have a fireball somewhere
what oh I got lucky
oh I got lucky forgot about that I got a
lucky shot like I just heard a noise and
my instinct was to just get out of the
way oh man
instincts Dark Souls since +1 ways to go
before the first boss fight really do I
not get to level that entire time then
you you have to go back to the Nexus are
you serious that is some horse trash
right there
well how are you faster than my swing
oh hello okay
all we got is this are to move there you
go I have superior reach damn it so I
don't there we go what a soldier Lotus
to you is that like more life or is that
that mana MP so up or left what do you
think for a second idea it's a bridge
yeah well three-hit combo and some grass
go up just a shitty grass so I'm saying
down did something I'm good
oh there you go thank you I missed
whoever said that earlier Oh how do we
kill these just oh that was [ __ ] do
you see that yeah dude no way right one
at time there's no boulders hey I'll
fight you where there's no bow and arrow
guys who oh hello I knew it you guys try
to trick me every time just like Dark
Souls 3 are you gonna breathe fire
no he's friends with them I did breathe
fire and you know can have a know I know
I know but it seemed too like there's
too many guys for me to have to like
kill there or it to make sense
yeah exactly Dark Souls 3 right ok well
it's been three two then for me for me
it was in three yeah they like you I
thought he did burn him you might have
not stayed on long enough
okay here's asked here's ask are you
serious you want to burn you does he am
I supposed to run all the way across the
bridge I think you were supposed to get
him to me
oh come on right here come on
you're barren dude you're burn so I'm
gonna do it you know what come on dragon
I've just pulled two more guys so I
believe the left might actually be the
way to go okay just a death trap well
like I said John items are never worth
it
some items mmm two-for-one baby all
right so we should we go this way yeah
someone said wrong bridge Royal Lotus
cures poison so soldier load is curious
to the plague yes oh don't go this way
no there's a lot of burned bodies
they're coming look at all that loot I
thought you said was never worth it it's
not worth it but is he gonna come back
over here probably fudge man hey booty
calls death
yeah I agree loot equals death I said
that earlier in the stream okay here the
dragon
if you go left in some optional
sidewalls yeah those dragons are
optional
oh they're completely optional yeah okay
is he gonna do it this time yep there it
is there it is
if you all right now Ron cool I got to
run all the way yeah
Oh cuz he does it oh no just kidding
yo I think he's protecting this bridge
oh wait yeah I booked it
but there's so guys though Ron I hear
him I hear dragon out I hear dragon bro
hey I hear a dragon
alright alright did you not hear the
flapping of the wings and that didn't
make you nervous at all
yeah look away would have happened I
took a while though you had time did
more than enough time right do you think
he's gone
I gave him aside you think he's baiting
me he's baiting you for sure I know here
thank you going just run
taya shook uh hell yeah I'm shook you
take crazy for that loot that's good
damn right man Marcel is this the boss
so I gotta go all the way back down yeah
there should be uh what's that that's
the boss alright so where do I go
where's the fast way back it's gotta be
a foul that's so reassuring something
yeah
can't hide secrets from me is that good
I don't even turpentine do anything
spray like a upgrading material or
something how bad this weapon durability
play a factor in this
why why why why all right I just have to
argue these guys cuz apparently my
they're doing that just like gets they
get the auto block it was like whatever
alright time for phalanx great great are
we going the right way chat I think so
sorry bombs are they frustrating in the
sense that like I can't actually gauge
how much distance they're giving right
like throw it at like it seems like okay
yep worth got him John Luke all part of
the plan okay oh oh yeah
what is that okay good
come on really he looks so weak to fire
oh I almost fell oh my heart oh why
don't I get to pick that up just carry
that on your back yeah oh yeah why not
oh is that another one yeah yeah typical
yes yeah yeah you're on the right way
though definitely just fall off knock
them off
I was get worried you're gonna fall off
- yeah you guys there you go
goddammit got to make sure sure yeah you
never know how far once we might take
some sort of fire damage I'm trying to
recall if you throw it or it's like you
clip it sword or something do a manner
I'll be fine
yeah it's actually slow
I wanted to see how far over it would I
oh what's that some hard stones or
something Oh so this would be if I had
gotten so I didn't even need that
shortcut the other one cuz like we we
opened the other door now it's a safety
thing it's the safety so I should go
level oh [ __ ] now and then fight or just
die I mean if you die you can that's
true that's true that's true
oh god yes we can I feel good I feel
good I'm gonna die to the boss alive so
I would assume the boss is like a bigger
version of those small guys yeah alright
so I'm learning in return right all
right we're gonna give normally we ended
12th area but since we're at the boss
should try we're gonna try that oh it's
a temporary what something is a
temporary fire enchanter your sword yeah
the turpentine the turpentine yes so
that's useful on the boss I was trying
to remember yes the boss is weak to fire
what's up Phillip so I should be using
that how do I set those shortcuts though
like shouldn't I be able to is it just
down oh yeah so you just equip it to one
of those was it in equip then I need to
change
Oh where's black maiden I need your baby
come where where is she it's not that
statue right at the bottom no she's in
the middle sometimes she's hanging up
here I want to sash where is she
you're supposed to be in the same spot
no the crime oh where is she turns out
you can level up John Luke not until you
beat the boss sorry Jeff he's worried
we're spoiling too much of the game if I
want a cheat way
just ask got it I'm gonna try not to
cheat but if anyone knows where the
black maidens at that would be pretty
helpful right now I'm probably gonna
just do like stamina and health it's
Mike it's Mike or we could try equipping
that bastard sword but I'm guessing the
bastards or it's like a two-handed
weapon I think so she's up here
[Music]
I'm thinking we go higher
there technically is a higher floor but
I don't think she'd be up there made in
my heart that's right Kaka Jesus she's
she's being an elusive one right now
though when we need her the most
you can't level up have to kill boss
first great oh okay sorry
thanks for nothing gentlemen false sense
of security here I thought I was like
yeah I'm gonna drop some points in a
stamina my bigger this is the least here
we go
someone else is on the bottom floor
alright there's enough people saying
that uh you got a you gotta kill the
boss to do it so up look foggy door get
that good fog door going okay so we're
gonna use the shitty grass first see you
know what sucks about that though is
like so like you know the other games
maybe this learned you equip the
turpentine I did and maybe in other
games they learned this well like you
should in theory be able to like level
up before fighting the boss like you
shouldn't have to fight a boss about
right here we go oh he's got baby ones
too [ __ ] how is this fair oh my god they
all they all just alright cool
yup frame rate right yeah hard move the
frame rate on this one floor up does he
spot I'm not gonna ask
I'll just that's got to be the weak spot
the bright spot oh my god there's so
many of them this reminds me of like
that Deacons fight I believe the spot
above the grass is magic I can't even
target all my frame rates
[Music]
alright alright just gotta be calm and
collective can you even backs out these
guys okay
[Music]
oh hello
cool
good test
[Music]
firebombing the big boss see what that
does
[Music]
but I like don't want to waste health
trying to like chomp it's a similar
blood-borne you have to lease encounter
a boss to level yeah but that sounds
about right like I don't think I want to
like waste any herbs yet just because
can I respect
[Music]
I did nothing I'm gonna hit that other
guy do a lot of Hamill 54 is like a
paltry amount per feeling I'm going
about this the wrong way
do we waste herbs right now or just
commit to dying and starting over
Oh
a lot of people are recommending stuff I
mean I'm gonna let you try a couple
times yeah yeah yeah I wonder if it's
like one of those things where you just
have to like alright I'll try to figure
it out okay the only thing with this is
like it usually takes like X amount of
times like lives to even figure it out
and is this game like most of the other
games where it it has like multiple
phases
[Music]
bosses really I kind of get to his back
like you know what else does boss
reminds me of that stupid spider boss
rom you know what here I'm just I I
really want to Yolo probably my least
favorite boss have you seen someone kill
him with a flamethrower those pretty
funny taste this extra long stream today
yeah man hey you go hit him
[Music]
just like 20 the 30 more of those swings
and okay that was a strong arm over
there
old ass cameras is too bad the server's
are going offline rip that's why were
plans gotta get he's gotta play it yes
I've never played this game for dark
souls or dark souls 2 alright so those
things look like they stick to him oh
god this is like one of those things are
apply teaching you to get around his
back but he's got so many of these
little spawned bastards
that's like he's never exposed really
except for those couple times where I
like literally ran an entire circle but
that camp I just don't buy that as that
does is the strategy cuz like I would
think you just feel to kill these guys
no no no that was definitely not the
strategy I thought I could run through
everything and just be a man and attack
him and no that's not the way the boss
is so freakin dark - okay they clump up
yeah I want y'all to clump up [ __ ] gonna
smoke no this game isn't all mine only
you can play offline but there are just
a lot of elements about this game that
is really unique with the online servers
on so while you can tighten please don't
play this game after it goes offline
people are gonna be trying to like play
it or replay it one last time hit that
turf hopefully get some people who are
still playing and experience all right I
saw Ben janko's thing he said to light
it let his ass on fire but yeah and if
you commit to using the turf and then
you wasted them isn't it gonzo oh my god
no damage alright it's definitely got to
be fire of some sort because
your five men
all right do some grass all right go for
it
really
oh wow the damage difference is enormous
yes also I don't know if you've noticed
by
[Music]
what his help people generated how cuz
he ate some gobs I only noticed him like
shedding them not like oh my God he's
back to full life that's on the chat
says hey don't be a brad items are three
years
[Music]
oh no well I don't know I I come from
the school of like you know like that's
how I used to always play like JRPGs I
would never use any of my items I want
to save them yeah then you never use
them no the turf is out a big moment and
that was just every reason I'm doing wow
I just made that game way harder
[Music]
it's fired we should just use a
turpentine huh
mungus boss ever am i right guys
that
yeah yeah you better keep saying the
same ended up with 15 mega elixirs just
happy
a little bit bold nope nope no no no
now there's not going so well not yet
I was worried we needed to go yeah but
then will I even have the turpentine
left to fight home at that point no I
found it off of a dead body oh I see the
turpentine is out now that's fine we're
gonna one-shot this [ __ ] like kind of
there's like one little crevice but all
these aspirin
[Music]
[Music]
it's open
oh no no no I
where are you open you got it boss
they're worth it oh yeah right tutorial
boss yeah it might have been easy when
you don't know you just don't know you
know I don't know man jeez Easter fire
bombs
I was trying actually earlier but it was
[Music]
because they yeah I kind of figured that
I kind of figured once you said his life
was back that like chances already kind
of absorbed he was absorbed in the
little dudes but I should have been
yellowing the little guys with the fire
yeah sure
in case we continue for some reason it
did not take 45 minutes goob it was more
like 15 to 20 of me running in circles
trying to think that I could just hit it
like in my mind I was like I just gotta
hit him where he's exposed because I
guess weird got like coming from like
present or future of these games right
and going back where like you said it's
like a very mechanics based right like
I'll let her talk first before I finish
my thought
like I don't know I don't feel like in
blood-borne you ever had to use like
fire paper I mean in some cases it
helped right like I think it made like
vicar Amelia or whatever is like weak to
fire so like it definitely helps but you
could beat her without it it's like and
it's not like the edge is that much more
you know what I mean like I don't think
like that that difference was like as
big like whereas this is clear like if I
don't use fire you know there was a fire
lover that kills all the little ones
yeah see like I wouldn't be shocked cuz
like there was like two little things I
don't know like I am NOT shocked when I
kind of find out on these games like
this always a defeat a boss
Mendel awaits the that must make that a
joke then if you kill all the little so
basically I go up till I get some
explanation I got to talk to your other
thing before you will actually help me
out great yes three yeah this games a
ps3 excuse there was another stair wall
that guy keep going all the way up
wait till we get to the next classic
it's like 20 times the next bosses the
one I'm thinking out that bosses it
kills you like it's going time so
probably 40 for me I'd love to see what
they do with flame workers oh don't do
this or darn sure I bet that wouldn't
have worked until I killed the boss I
feel like we're going the wrong way oh
oh yeah this is like the boards ha ha
that's very cool
so this isn't where we need to be huh
trophies okay then we're going around
you were on the right floor to where we
were standing at that one spot
yeah flame worker is one of the more
infamous bosses bosses in this game for
the fruity
Oh God flame lurker fun times was it is
it this oh god I wasn't sure if they're
alive or not
[Music]
where is that on the other side just
check around
we have long ago I and one of the
monumental that there is something just
had the right now once we to great cut
seed in the distant past the back story
under a benevolent rule the world was
United owing to the sole arts until I
lost for power cause the awakening of
the old one across the lands oh no I
think you can still get it because you
can go back to thanks B we were able to
love the old one I hope to get only
after turning it in and half the world
such a lust for power the phalanx of
souls the one you use to make the
scrapings oh that's great they entrusted
six eldest with six precious opts games
didn't we kill one already that the king
of a small yet diligent land he did that
one to the king of the borrower's
underground the dwarves one survived
queen of the great ivory tower falls
exhale like Eileen with masked the semen
of The Tempest washed pink shadow men
and the last the great Giants the
northern lands it's funny how much play
on well since I never played these smart
move even three though there's Marian
three that's a very similar an area in
this one I remember playing and being
like wow this is just don't recall the
names but think of that yeah yeah
definitely
alright so now I can level oh all right
let's go do that and then we'll call it
a stream but uh yeah yeah okay so just
surprised for me that it's not as slow
as I thought it'd be so I probably
should have gave these games a chance
sooner
yeah man yeah I think you'd like just
stay away from Dark Souls - you should
try it if you ever get the chance I have
it I think you should or should
definitely play one though I have one of
them I either I've worn it and - or just
one I have like one of the prepare to
die edition
[Music]
okay don't know what those do okay yeah
all right get that soul power give me
that power after all touch the demon
inside me let these boneless souls
become thine own sure I seek soul power
HP stamina what I like gain like no
attack power this is a typical standard
you know get your life up I'm all I'm
always about like three stats it's like
life stamina like whatever your main
stats typically I am then yeah that was
cool
so thanks to everyone for tuning in I
appreciate it
you know now that demon souls online is
gonna get shut down February 28th I
think of 2018 so you got to get on use
you're scraping spear maybe we'll do
that at some point yeah gank some people
take their levels but yeah we have our
best of 2017 coming up soon as I
mentioned we're gonna do like kind of
like a countdown of us playing some of
those games through like almost like
seven to eight days like one game per
day from 10 all the way down to one I'm
sure you'll be on something maybe we'll
see we'll do our deliberation so that's
on its way so just so you guys know tune
into that we're not gonna actually have
a lobby this week we normally have that
on Wednesdays we're gonna be starting to
do our deliberations and things like
that so if you guys were curious sorry
that won't happen tomorrow I haven't
figured out the game but there's always
default destiny - especially since
I think expansion comes out next week
right so yeah we always have this to
come back to you I would love to see you
beat this game I mean I wonder how long
that's gonna take
it'll kind of be like it's like it'll be
our version of Knievel we just have to
come up with some souls thing where like
I go through one demon souls of one and
two and then eventually we can go
through like blood-borne and like
actually have fun playing okay oh I'll
have played sorry I'll have fun playing
those games I'm not saying that these
games aren't fun - it's just that
there's a special place in my heart with
bloodworm but uh thank you John Lee for
guiding me being the guide and yeah
that's about it yeah cool thanks you
guys later
[Music]
[Music]
you